[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'ancient par
les sports aujourd'hui c'est la rentrée
de cette émission pour le premier numéro
de cette saison 2018 2019 il y aura
comme d'habitude des analyses des débats
et des duels acharnés entre nos
brillants chroniqueurs et ils sont en
grande forme aujourd'hui après de
longues vacances estivales ils sont cinq
autour de cette table je vous propose
une présentation spéciale rentrée des
classes on commence à ma droite musique
à l'école c'était le délégué de classe
il aime instaurer des débats il est bien
également débriefer des cours après la
sonnerie toujours irréprochable sur le
plan du comportement nous gratifie une
nouvelle fois de sa présence le capital
yens dujarrier pistard des clubs de
vélizy 78 est avec nous mon cher michael
quant à lui très très bien vous avez
essayé de bonnes vacances oui oui de
très très bonnes vacances
comme toujours nous tous savons que je
suis toute l'année en vacances délégués
de classe sa façon bien une année
seulement n'a pas voté pour vous les
suivantes je lui ai présenté en face à
ma gauche un musique à l'école c'était
la fille la plus populaire à faisait
tourner la tête de tous les garçons et
les filles était jalouse d'elle mettant
studieuse a préféré se consacrer à ses
cours et assez de voir notre
ambassadrice de charme
hélène de la grange ou professeurs de
pole dance à versailles nous fait le
plaisir encore une fois d'être avec nous
sur ce plateau et sera vite revenir est
ravie de reprendre
moi j'aime bien partir en vacances mais
j'aime bien revenir voilà de vacances
ont été sympathique oui toujours trop
courtes
je désire donc pu être présente sur sion
pas les sports la première émission d'un
dessin on repasse de l'autre côté un
musique à l'école on le surnommait le
petit génie lequel et où surtout il
avait les meilleures notes sur ce
plateau ne lui auront trouvé un autre
surnom le zorro yvelines
le vengeur masqué hao nous coûterait
d'autres cavaliers international sort
avec nous sans masque pendant une heure
bonjour raul
comment allez-vous michael vous avez
passé de bonnes vacances
merci pour vos collègues assez studieuse
les miennes comme toujours le petit
génie pas vraiment le génie dans le
passé mais bon on va laisser paraître
cette légende on verra ça dans
l'émission en tout cas on passe à ma
gauche musique à l'école c'était un
véritable boute-en-train toujours
présent pour faire des blagues d'après
la légende cet enfant terrible a fait
mourir de rire à l'un de ses profs
l'ancien coach de plaisir du plaisir
rugby-club genlis va faire mal à mettre
le feu sur ce plateau pendant une heure
comme d'habitude quand allez-vous gens
super forme très heureux de vous
retrouver dans votre démission
je suis super bourg alors juste une
question les fans de cette émission
attendent ça avec impatience
comment étaient vos vacances est ce
qu'elles ont été représentés excellent
had a très reposante tête après pour la
nouvelle saison
je suis un coureur plein forme par
rapport à tout casser on termine à ma
droite musique comme à chaque rentrée il
ya toujours une petite nouvelle et cette
petite nouvelle aujourd'hui devrait
faire des étincelles j'en suis sûr elle
sera notre spécialiste golfe et surtout
à ryder cup
la golfeuse professionnelle alexandra
bonetti vous fait l'honneur de venir sur
ce talk comment vous sentez vous
alexandra dans cette première super
équipe vous avez bien en tout genre là
les nouvelles donc il faut y aller
doucement avec l'agent mais on commence
à sympathiser lacombe initiation à 10h à
leurs protégés
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de l'aa super tribune qui
sera construite pour cette ryder cup
2018 qui se tiendra à 50 ans les vignes
du 25 au 30 septembre nous parlerons
également du futur centre d'entraînement
du psg à poissy les contours du projet
ont été à dévoiler mais avant de
développer ces thèmes on va parler de la
venue de tiger woods au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
on commence donc par du golfe un tigre
va rugir au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le capitaine
de la sélection américaine jim furyk a
décidé de sélectionner
d'ailleurs vous dit l'homme aux 14
tournois du grand chelem pour la ryder
cup 2018 sans septembre une invitation
attendu après le bel été du golfeur sur
les meilleurs tournois mondiaux en
écoute philippe il a tout du golf
national
au micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
il finit fille née dans l'est dans les
six premiers à l'open britannique il est
deuxième à lui et spidey
il est toujours devant quoi ce cirque en
randonnée tiger il revient aux affaires
en plus on sent un joueur en tout cas il
me paraît beaucoup plus détendue
beaucoup plus ouvert on sent un joueur
qui est qui et qui moi qui ait moins de
tournées vers lui un peu plus vers les
autres et je pense que ça a dû penchés
également dans la balance dans le dans
le choix du capitaine américain alors
tiger woods au golf national ce n'est
pas une première le golfeur va y
participent aux championnats du monde
amateurs en 1994 sur le parcours de
l'albatros
mais il n'avait pas gagné mais ce fut
mais ces dames la question sur ce thème
est-ce que c'est impossible de 7 est
impossible de ne pas le prendre sur
cette compétition
oui ou non vous mettez plutôt que j de
prendre genlis vous écoute donc pour
vous c'était impossible de ne pas le
prendre c'est une figure du golfe donc
même ceux qui connaissent pas trop le
golfe connaissent tiger woods ne serait
ce que pour ses performances extra
sportives en plus donc qui a défrayé la
chronique abandonner mes règles pour le
pour le golf c'est à la même époque est
resté bas les a tellement si de
nombreuses publicités dans le passé un
jeu il vit je crois que c'est un dd dans
tous les sports il ya toujours des
sportifs comme ça qui font parler de la
discipline par rapport à lille par
rapport à leur image
il a fait partie à l'époque c'était
ballesteros je disais et c'était un
joueur connu du golfe qui a fait
connaître le bol fait aujourd'hui c'est
tiger woods quoi pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas vraiment le golf v tout
le monde
quasiment tout le monde connaît tagueurs
route donc au niveau de 7
compétitionne qui est ok qu'il a piqué
la plus grande du golfe
on ne pouvait pas se passer du neuron la
figure du golf mondial
il ya déjà il a quand même gagné sa
place alors il devait faire partie de
l'encadrement ils devaient tous capital
vice-capitaine voilà j'avais dire sous
coach il devait 10 capitaine mais voilà
maintenant il a gagné sa place avec les
résultats de l'état des derniers mois et
des derniers tournois
donc voilà non il ne pouvait pas se
passer de taille aux il y avait pas de
raison sans passer par ce qu ils ne s'en
sont quand même passés sur les dernières
chalet dernière ryder qui n'a pas
toujours participe alors à 2,4 malgré
l'aura qui peut qui peut dégager voilà
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas participé aux
deux dernières ryder cup
j'ai pas tous les chiffres les hémois
hélène je rejoins ce qu'ils disent on
l'attendait de toute façon c'est la
figure emblématique de la génération
golf de maintenant et ces dernières
années comme disait jan voilà les
résultats étaient pas
rendez-vous maintenant les derniers
tournois il est quand même bien remonté
on le voit dans l'interview il remonte
tellement que le comment dire on invite
mais voilà pour jouer c'est l'un des
meilleurs golfeurs américains sur ces
derniers mois et donc il le faut c'est
avec son bras bonetti vous qui est une
grande fan de tiger woods de prison pour
faits totalement légitime qui soit dans
l'équipe il a gagné sa place comme tu
dis les retombées médiatiques en plus
son timbre aux etats unis c'est plus du
double sa double audience double grâce à
lui sur chaque tournoi où il participe
il ya deux fois plus de téléspectateurs
que c'est une palissade et moi je me
rends compte aussi parce que je suis pas
du genre à garder les tournois réguliers
du pid j ai tout est là vu qu'il y avait
d'ailleurs j'ai fait l'effort de
regarder même dell jeu justement donc
tout le monde
tout le monde ressent cette la présence
de tiger sur un tournoi que ce soit
l'union golfeurs les golfeurs s'est
dernièrement fallait dès jeudi pour être
sûr de pouvoir le voir justement par
rapport à la médiatisation on va écouter
philippe il a tout à l'équipe américaine
avait gagné à le score par équipes mais
il n'avait pas finir les 1er mai où tu
avais fait voilà un beau tournoi mais
avait pas que du premier duel
ce n'était pas la bonne ni ce n'était
pas la bonne interwiew mais en tout cas
c'était par rapport à ses performances
au golf national lors de championnats
amateurs vous en souvenez alexandra deux
ans alors il a également sorti on le
disait un livre il ya quelques jours
tiger woods est la biographie mais
performant voilà en voilà en ce moment
là le livre à l'écran vous êtes d'accord
avec vos collègues
raul c'est un personnage hors du commun
vraiment taillé route comme tous les
comme toutes les légendes un petit peu
un petit peu à part dans les différents
sports
l'image de rodger federer ou ou autre je
pense que il est déjà un atout
indispensable d'un point de vue
médiatique pour l'événement et surtout
là on est dans un format de compétition
par équipes et étant le joueur le plus
et le plus expérimenté de cette équipe
là il pourra aussi servir un petit peu
de support et de facteurs de facteurs
sophrologique pour reste de l'équipe
donc ça fait beaucoup de beaucoup de
facteurs qui font qu'il était
indispensable de penser qui peut attirer
l'attention peut-être sur cette ryder
cup je pense tous les gérants privés de
celui la pression sur les autres joueurs
ouais c'est que les européens vont
peut-être avoir vraiment l' envie de
battre tiger en fait donc c'est
peut-être un as et un avantage pour nous
pour notre équipe mais pour les
américains pas forcément et
donc on va voir on va voir mais c'est
génial qu'ils soient là après tiger
woods ce n'est pas forcément un joueur
hyper performant sur la ryder cup en
sept participations le sportif ne l'a
emporté qu'une seule fois c'était en
1999 il n'a remporté que 13 victoires en
33 matches mais il n'a perdu qu'une
seule fois en sept matches en individuel
c'est à dire qui ne performent pas en
équipe c'est aussi ça le problème
peut-être avec son agonie team et je
pense que ce petit temps mort dans sa
vie lui a fait beaucoup de bien on le
voit sur les tournois là il est beaucoup
plus accessible beaucoup plus sourire
alias pizza il a attendu brooks cap car
que qui finissait parti pour le
féliciter il a fini deuxième donc on
sent vraiment un état d'esprit qui a
beaucoup changé chez lui d'ailleurs vous
avez quand même dit à quelques années le
golf c'est moi
jean-mi flux sont comme tout sportif
comme tout sportif qui qui qui côtoient
le sommet il a perdu sa voix champion se
doit d'avoir un ego démesuré on ne peut
pas devenir fermé si on n'a pas cette 7
voilà ce qui arrive cette soif de gagner
2 de vouloir écraser des adversaires si
vous êtes trop gentil et être assez
jeune mais en même temps il n'a pas tort
aujourd'hui tu le dis quand on demande à
n'importe qui de citer un joueur de golf
c'est tiger route qui va sortir en
numéro il n'y a pas de donc en effet
dans nos locaux sel et bien je suis bien
sûr moi je suis entièrement d'accord
avec ce que tu dis est au tout début il
ya deux golfeurs que je connaisse et
lester rose l'espagnol et tiger woods
après le reste on va en entendre un
périodique
car il me revient pas le nom du
troisième avec 500 abonnés encore je le
disais précédemment c'est pas forcément
un jour de riders que tiger woods il
fallait quand même le prendre dans
l'équipe
à votre avis oui parce que là je pense
que l'individualisme c'est les traits de
caractère d'un sportif jeunes mais au
fur et à mesure de l'expérience on se
bonifie
et j'imagine que dans pendant ces trois
années de récession avec des petits des
petits tourments dans sa vie privée ont
fait on fait un peu un examen de
conscience
un bilan de vie on en ressort avec
j'imagine des vertus un petit peu plus
collective le choix revient au
sélectionneur séduite et décidé de le
prendre si ça n'avait pas été un bon
élément pour l'équipe
il ne l'aurait pas pris le malgré le
résultat prendre l'exemple de benzema
qui n'intègre pas l'équipe de france
parce que didier deschamps pense qu'il
ne faut pas le faire donc là c'est la
responsabilité du sélectionneur
les résultats sont sans cesse honneur se
plante
mais ce n'est pas sa faute c'est d'où la
question sur tiger woods la ryder cup
est peut-être déjà réussi c'est ryder
cup 2018 avec la présence de tiger woods
à votre avis l'aisne oui je pense que il
ya déjà le succès de l'ehf a remis
voilà sur tiger woods c'est sûr de la
ryder cup après on attend les résultats
et cerise sur le gâteau oui mais en fait
c'est même un peu de gâteaux ou les gens
viennent par ça sera la cerise et tiger
au tibia taux réduits aux carrefours
16,7 des équipes
on continue donc de parler à de la ryder
cup vous l'aurez compris on connaît
désormais les noms des joueurs
sélectionnés pour les équipes
américaines et européennes chez les
américains on retrouvera notamment celui
que l'on surnomme la machine du kentucky
justin thomass les supporters pourront
voir également le prodigieux jordan
spitz
patrick reed le capitaine américain
vainqueur du masters d'augusta ou encore
dustin johnson
on notera également la présence de phil
mickelson qui jouera sa douzième ryder
cup c'est une belle équipe avec son
ballet si la plus belle équipe de tous
les temps où je pense oui
ne serait ce que par le ranking enfin
que c'est hallucinant la moyenne de leur
classement mondial en fait ces onze je
crois 75e
donc il connaît pas du tout le golf
banon qui atteste une jeune femme qui
est numéro deux mondial brusque et trois
excellents tout le monde est dans la
moyenne
alors du côté des européens est
également bien armés on retrouvera
notamment des joueurs d'expérience comme
le golfeur italien francesco molinari
l'anglais l'anglais justin rose et le
nord irlandais rory mcilroy qui a déjà
participé à quatre éditions
on retrouvera également des novices
comme l'anglais tommy fleetwood ainsi
que le suédois alex north end vainqueur
du dernier open de france
du côté des invitations le capitaine
thomas bjorn a décidé de retenir quatre
golfeurs d'expérience avec les anglais
paul quasi et ian poulter le suédois
henrik stenson et l'espagnol sergio
garcia qui honorera sa 9e sélection en
écoute la réaction de philippe pilato il
ya beaucoup de voir où ça va être la
première ryder cup et
des stenson des garcia 1 permettront
justement de pouvoir assurer
certainement ces joueurs là et après
chez les jeunes bien évidemment c'est
les joueurs de demain donc mais qui pour
open et redoutable riz la question sur
ce thème qui est favori pour porter
cette ryder cup c'est rouge vous votez
rouge pour les américains et vert pour
les européens ils sont abonnés qui a
pris parti
on fait un petit duel entre alexandra
bonetti et les gens vont commencer
donc vous vous êtes européen survient
malgré le fait qu'ils aient pas de
france et ce me désole de cette équipe
mais il y aura quand même deux français
dans l'encadrement
oui de l'intérieur et havret et raphaël
jacquelin parce que c'est chez nous donc
les un peu déçu une compensation en
maniant non mais pour moi je vois
l'équipe d'europe parce que justement je
seront les attend pas on parle tellement
de cette équipe ce grand de l'équipe
américaine avec tiger woods à la cerise
sur le gâteau tout notre monde est
focalisé là dessus sur lui et en
laquelle il ya quand même des joueurs
qui s'est pas d c'est pas des novices
notamment le numéro un mondial si je ne
trompe pas voilà justin russie gérant un
mondial voilà donc bon donc l'expérience
est lui aussi surtout l'expérience
actuelle par rapport au niveau de ces
joueurs là et donc moi je pense je je je
je je pense qu'ils vont me faire la
surprise
même s'ils sont pas tendus et on n'est
jamais aussi bon en france que quand on
n'est pas favoris et là c'est l'europe
oui mais c'est en france cette enfance
c'est chez nous à vue en cours elles
sont abolis
je trouve que la carrure de chaque
individualité de l'équipe américaine est
quand même très forte
et en plus de cela depuis l'édition
précédente il ya vraiment une cohésion
dans le groupe qu'ils avaient pas
forcément avant quand ils ont perdu les
trois éditions d'affilée donc parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de
ceux de la nouvelle génération jordaens
piscine thomass etc qui était à
l'université ensemble et c'est donc il
ya vraiment qu'ils ont tous 25 ans voilà
donc ils se connaissent et hyper bien
c'est des copains donc leur petite
défaillance auparavant dans les douves
commence à changer et
donc oui et tiger qui a jamais gagné en
europe très envie de gagner je pense que
c'est peut-être la dernière ryder cup on
ne sait pas ce qui va se passer donc non
plein d'atouts pour cette équipe
américaine
je pense j'entends des choses qui me
surprennent quand même parce que l'âge
des joueurs pour moi le golf était un
sport de vieux et cinq ans etc d une
très jeune aussi donc
donc aujourd'hui on joue au golf très
jeune et on devient performant très
jeune pour moi j'ai le souvenir à
l'époque de ballesteros par exemple
d'avoir des devoirs des joueurs de golf
qui avait au delà 40 ans c'est plus tard
mais lui mais mais mais ses adversaires
avaient à peu près à peu près les même
âge c'était des générations un peu un
peu un peu passé et aujourd'hui donc je
m'aperçois que ce sont des jeunes
joueurs et qui est qui arrive à être
performant à haut niveau déjà déjà
jeunes alors que qu'avant c'était voilà
c'était vraiment juste une aparté mais
pas pour parler pour parler d'autre
chose que de la ryder cup
voilà c'est un sport que l'on découvre
jeunes et on devient performant à un âge
de maturité dont beaucoup d'autres
sports maintenant il est un peu dure à
bord d'une auto revient sur les
européens ont remporté six des neuf
dernières éditions et l'aisne parce que
vous pensez qu'il ya un impact
psychologique sur cette compétition
maintenant du côté européen alors que
les américains ont dominé vraiment les
premiers ryder cup c'est sûr que donc il
ils sont quand même en sont quand même
en supériorité puisqu'ils ont remporté
plusieurs tournois et plus que les
américains maintenant en face comme tu
disais on a quand même des personnalités
des personnages et des performeurs en
face qui ont de quoi impressionner qui
peuvent vraiment déstabiliser l'équipe
européenne et c'est valable même si ils
ont remporté plusieurs tournois
d'affilée là on n'a pas la certitude
voilà on peut pas vraiment savoir qui va
gagner
et voilà je pense que il faut pas se
laisser impressionner europe
ouais moi je pense enfin je pense qu'on
a plus de on a moins de chance de gagner
cette année
face à une équipe comme comme celle
qu'on a en face donc aux états unis pour
raul
finalement me tête les individualités
peut-être américaine qui sont ultra
forte
est ce que ça peut leur desservir
justement à ces américains
voilà on prend l'exemple du tailleur
vous on le disait précédemment 13
victoires en 33 matches alors que
c'était vraiment la superstar sur
circuit américain
il a passé 6 183 semaines numéro un
mondial est pourtant finale mais n'a
remporté qu'une seul rider qui me semble
qu'il est pire il y a
new très rapidement classement mondial a
envie moi non moi je pense qu'ils vont
vraiment bénéficié d'une spirale
positive
j'aurais j'ai tendance à accorder moelle
avantage du fait de jouer à domicile
pour faire pencher la balance mais là je
vais à domicile non parce qu'il ya pas
de france est donc finalement ça va pas
c'est pas un facteur qui va alors
d'éviter les tribus y aura terminé et
100 grammes c'est quand même dans les
tribunes
oui mais les joueurs ont fait le
déplacement de l'étranger je dire s'est
il ya tous ces facteurs là du fait de se
déplacer ne pas avoir les marques du
domicile l'équipe européenne ne va pas
bénéficier de sa danse et rend donc bout
moi j'ai j'ai comme le sentiment que ça
tourne en faveur de des états unis les
années visualité américaine vous pensez
il ya du jard y est que tout simplement
ils peuvent craquer en pleine
compétition mais je connais pas le
principe complet de la ryder cup
donc il ya des matchs en double le
vendredi et le samedi
et le dernier jour de compétition le
dimanche ce ne sont que des simples donc
match en double c'est à dire qu'il y en
a qui jouent premier coup 1-1 qui joue
le coup suivant l'accord évoqué
maintenant ça reste ça reste la qualité
du joueur qui qui qui qui l'emportent
c'est pas c'est pas comme un match de
tennis ou la réaction doit se faire doit
se faire tout de suite vous avez temps
d'analyser le couple vous vous devez
jouer il ya après voilà faut avoir la
précision pour faire le coup qu'on a
décidé de faire maintenant voilà les
américains sont aaron king un peu
meilleur que les que les européens moi
je
votre europe parce que je peux pas je
suis trop chauvin donc je peux pas je
peux pas dire bravo à l'est des
américains je suis désolé c'est comme ça
maintenant ce qui est sûr c'est que il
faut que le mieux pour que la ryder cup
soit soit réussie c'est que tout le
monde joue à son meilleur niveau et que
les coûts soient soient les plus beaux
pour pour pour tout le monde voilà on
veut qu'ils nous fassent ddd one by one
shot et encore je suis pas sûr que ce
soit possible d'être haut en a je suis
pas sûr que ce soit possible sur le golf
national
mais voilà des superbes approche et puis
des puits des potes de des potes de loin
quoi l'aller ça qui compte
alexandra bonetti la cohésion d'équipé
vraiment important dans une ryder cup
peut-être plus que sur une compétition
notre compétition ah oui a pas photo et
je pense que c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que thomas ce viol l'autre le capitaine
européen a choisi sergio garcia parce
que honnêtement golfique mans là c'est
la cata non mais il a joué je ne sais
pas cette hui ryder cup sérgio il a
marqué un nombre de points mais sur le
dernier open de france 2 il a fini
huitième la loi dernier open de france
et apparemment c'est quelqu'un qui dans
le vestiaire est hyper important en fait
et donc au final les doubles il ya que
huit joueurs qui les jouent
il ya quatre autres joueurs qui peuvent
servir à autre chose dans les vestiaires
a motivé il ya comme adil rami pour
l'équipe de france par exemple de
football il y avait bien de prendre ce
lien ce parallèle parce que aujourd'hui
on s'adresse à nos spectateurs ici qui
sont pas spécialement golfeur est donc
en effet dira qu' il va y avoir des
joueurs qui sont là pour
pour expliquer ce que doivent faire les
autres et pour l'ambiance et voilà et en
effet prendre l'exemple de délit était
très sympa il ya quelques années de ça
par exemple tiger woods et phil
mickelson ne s'entendait pas du tout sur
la ryder cup 2004 notamment et ils
avaient perdu leur match qu'ils avaient
disputée en double alors que sur le
papier c'était peut-être la meilleure
équipe possible
oui mais les doutes c'est pas seulement
lié au classement c'est quand même une
cohésion une entente donc là ils seront
pas ensemble certains n'étaient pas les
mettre ensemble à une certaine toujours
pas si ça va mal ça sert apparemment
réchauffer entre les deux la femme de
alors le fait de jouer à la maison
genlis vous l'avez dit c'est sera le
facteur déterminant pour les européens
en sachant que les américains n'ont pas
gagné en europe depuis 1993 et bien
voilà plus de cinq ans et guillaume
vaganay on va gagner les américains et a
vu six de talbot du est comme ça que les
mains on peut avoir une super belle
compétition et pour moi ça favorisera
l'europe
dernier facteur correction draps bonetti
également c'est l'albatros forcément qui
est très compliqué et les américains
n'ont pas l'habitude de se déplacer sur
l'open de france est ce que ça peut
jouer également je pense que les
américains soient pas vrai c'est
parcours qui est quand même assez étroit
avec des robes costaud donc les
bombardiers américains là qui tape l'a
330 m il va falloir être précis et pas
forcément sortir le driver surtout les
trous et ça je sais que ça peut nous
avantager
les européens sont plus précis que les
américains oui les américaines ont
ensuite certains justement sorte surtout
le trou on va pas vous laisser dire ça
aujourd'hui on va passer à la troisième
partie de cette émission à la tribune
justement elle concerne donc la super
tribune qui a été construite pour la
compétition elle fait à 22 mètres de
haut
6800 places assises des chiffres qui
permettent à la ryder cup 2018 de
s'inscrire dans l'histoire de la
compétition avant même d'avoir commencé
sa capacité est cinq fois supérieure à
celle de la dernière édition organisée
en 2016 aux etats unis les jours
amateurs du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'en
reviennent pas on les écoute
allez impressionnante année elle est
belle elle est grande pour le départ du
1 c'est parfait elle est immense
j'ai entendu dire qu'elle faisait 6000
places je suis impressionné la tribune
éphémère permettra d'avoir une vision de
11 sur 11 des 18 trous du parcours les
spectateurs pourront notamment voir le
premier coup de la compétition le
vendredi 28 septembre
on écoute le directeur du golf national
à paul hermitage l'ambiance autre numéro
1 est devenu quelque chose dans
l'héritage de la ryder cup c'est
mythique l'ambiance quand les joueurs
entrent dans l'arène et ce bruit
assourdissant donc je pense qu'on a
voulu l'amplifier encore plus parce que
non seulement il y aura les 6800
personnes à 6 mais il y aura aussi la
même voire dix mille personnes debout
la question sur ce thème ces tribus
l'est-elle construite juste pour rentrer
dans l'histoire
oui ou non on fait un petit dieu j'ai
pas le cerveau en bon élève et alexandra
un duel féminin
je l'avais je réponds non parce qu'elle
n'est pas faite que pour entrer dans
l'histoire
évidemment qu'une tribune de 6800 place
c'est juste énorme on n'a jamais vu ça
alors elle va rester
longtemps oui mais voilà on se répète
mais voilà ça va rester dans les
mémoires et ça ça monte 7h haider cup à
un niveau il peut enfin qu'on n'a pas vu
maintenant je pense que le
c'est pas uniquement ça qui va faire
rentrer ça ça qui va me faire entrer
leur aide comme dans l'histoire après ça
va être vraiment dont tiger woods on en
a parlé et la qualité de l'affrontement
entre les deux équipes et sa chevelure
ouais ouais en fait la tribune c'est
vraiment ce qu'on va regarder parce
qu'on ce qu'on voit en termes de moyens
déployés mais on attend les résultats de
l'équipe celle entre l'annoncé des
résultats voilà c'est ça aussi on laisse
finir le duel avec alexandra alexandra
c'est à vous non mais pour une vague et
français font les choses en grand on va
pas se plaindre que je trouve ça bien
mais en même temps le parcours est déjà
dessiné pour en forme de ce talent il ya
des buts qui ont été créés par la chaire
shipwrecked voilà dans les années 90 on
l'a conduite jusqu'au le terrain était
tout plat en fait au départ le national
et s'était créé pour être un stade donc
mais cette tribune de 20 mètres de haut
c'est exactement cinq fois plus grande
que celle des années précédentes mais
c'est un peu pour marquer le coup mais
bon je suis pas à contrarier
ouais je vois juste l'utilité c'est
qu'elle permet d'avoir une vision sur
plusieurs tronçons 18 / news8 alors on
sur 18 de loin oui marie de loin mais
très bonne vision sur le 1 2 le 12
octobre les premiers trous et
impressions minces un peu plus compliqué
sur sur un stade de l'ofs
on y va et jumelles parce que on sait
très bien que entre le moment où le
joueur va faire son pote de départ et
bien on ne peut pas être aux deux
endroits en même temps donc si on veut
pouvoir voir maintenant il faut et des
jumelles donc je pense que l'intérêt il
est là c'est de se dire quand tu es dans
la tribune je peux voir à plusieurs
endroits et je suis obligé de me
promener dans leur a pas qu'une tribune
y aura également une des tribunes qui
seront installés sur le site
nineteen par exemple en 2016 ou la
personne et il n'y avait pas de relief
du tout sur le parcours il y avait des
tribunes tout le monde a essayé hier
long du golf national là pour pour faire
une balade en vélo et en effet on voit
que ça bouge et que et que ben tous mais
tout et tout est mis en place quoi et c
est ça vous avez opéré professional pour
l'émission je suis les heures sup
attention la gamme de chariots genre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous de
cette tribu moi je ne pense je suis
rejouer alexandra parce qu'elle dit pour
une fois que l'on fait les choses en
grand
chez nous on est toujours dans ce plan
là on a fait une tribune un magnifique
elle sera plein et je suis certain mais
c'est pas trop bon peut-être enfin 1200
places injecting la glycémie 300 places
ouais mais trop grand sur le premier
trou c'est génial je trouve ça va
permettre et s'affaire aussi venir du
monde dans dix ans mais avec une tribune
comme ça je jeu peut-être la chance
d'être là et puis le pouvoir assister au
départ donc pour moi c'est un plus pour
moi c'est vraiment un plus
d'autant plus si ça continue à faire
beau comme ça si la cote d'une à sourire
ça va être ça va être magnifique
magnifique magnifique alexandra bonetti
c'est logique de l'avoir mis sur le trou
numéro un
l'ambiance est dingue sur leur moi j'ai
jamais fait de ryder cup j'ai juste fait
ce même cap donc l'équivalent féminin et
donc l'échelle est dix fois moins grande
mais tous les joueurs le disent que
c'est bien important la compétition l
arrivée du 18 mai ça se trouve les
machines iront même pas jusqu'au 18
tempêtes
alors on voit des images comme c'est
c'est la dernière en europe nous c'est
intéressant c'est important moi je
pensais qu'on allait jusqu'au 18 que
comme pour attendre classique et en
effet oui puisqu'il faut gagner plus de
trous pour pouvoir gagner la manche 6 3
7 5
dax est là et la super tri minh ira
également sur trou numéro 18
également il y aura moins de passes être
pas y arriver donc elle va être au 18
mai et 1000 places seulement sont
réservés pour lui la super tribune
le reste est libre d'accès donc il
faudra arriver tôt je sais pas à quelle
heure selon vous est il arrivé si on a
la chance d'avoir un prix pour ses
ennemis je crois que les portes ouvrent
à 6 heures je crois qu'il faut être con
mais thierry keller 4h 5h faut être
courageux que les golfeurs
ah oui mais là c'est une chouette riz
les deux ans en france alors vous plaint
de telles atteintes touchent le porte
sur place ont enregistré ou bien lors du
matin non pas 4 heures du matin
j'aimais ma quote j'ai essayé d'y aller
c'est complet pour l'instant j'ai un
filon sur le green
ces gens il est des lycées montag a
préféré choisir
après cette large page ryder cup on
change de sport on va parler rugby dans
notre rubrique résultats
[Musique]
premier match et première défaite pour
plaisir en fédérale 2 ce dimanche 9
septembre les jaune et bleu n'ont pas
réussi à rivaliser avec le marcquois
rugby dans leur stade
le score est sans appel 51 à 13 avec
huit essais inscrits par les visiteurs
comme on peut le voir sur ces images on
écoute la réaction de l'entraîneur
sébastien auront cali quand on maîtrise
aussi peu de choses un moment donné la
sanction est un peu obligatoire et
notamment les 3 4 premiers essais
comprends c'est que des défauts de notre
parc que l'adversaire va utilise à fond
voilà donc un problème reste c'est
logique
au total les visiteurs ont donc inscrit
huit essais dont cinq en deuxième
période une faillite défensive qui
s'explique principalement par une
reprise tardive des entraînements pour
une partie du groupe
c'est vrai que par rapport à ces grosses
écuries qui ont certainement des moyens
différents des nôtres ils ont repris
l'entraînement beaucoup plus tôt que
nous c'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui le
jeu est beaucoup plus vils et de leur
côté quoi on est sûr à un groupe qui
bouge un peu cette année les garçons qui
nous ont rejoints les automatismes sont
pas là les repères de jeu sont pas
encore là voilà on va travailler tous
ensemble pour essayer d'améliorer tous à
la question sur ce thème s'est défaite
était déjà inquiétante pur plaisir
oui ou non vous mettez vous fait un
petit duel entre hélène et hop vous
commencez donc pour vous c'est
inquiétant moite qui me ce qui me paraît
inquiétant c'est plutôt la manière
d'entamer la saison
à savoir que la raison ce soit les
vacances et qu'ils aient repris
l'entraînement plus tard que les autres
j'ai des seniors ça me paraît mais
j'imagine que ça c'est de ces depuis que
jean est partie a pu il ya plus de
discipline dans ce dans ce club
non mais ce qui me paraît inquiétant
c'est que il est ce que c'est un mois
pour moi c'est la raison la plus visible
nature qu'ils soient donc je comprends
pas trop la philosophie d'1 le coulage
ne disposait pas de tout son effectif
pour ce match ça m'arrivait c'est en
tous cas intelligence et d'entamer une
saison de cette manière là si on a des
attentes si on a des obligations de
résultats on peut avoir des raisons
physiques des raisons bien plus enfin
moi pour moi ça me paraît très léger
quoi ce qui me paraît inquiétant c'est
la raison puisque hellemmes
je vends ma détresse que ce que dit raul
en fait le avoir un mauvais match en
début de saison c'est pas c'est pas
inquiète enfin c'est pas dramatique on
joue on joue pas sa saison sur un seul
match mais en effet les moyens enfin le
que l'effectif soit pas de présent que
pour cause de vacances comme tu l'a 10
et pas entamé leur
conduire leur reprise plutôt on peut se
poser la question dans quel état
d'esprit ils sont après faut voir
vraiment dans les prochains matchs et ça
se réveille un peu
voilà un match voilà c'est pas encore
c'est pas encore dramatique mais veut
salariés voilà ça va falloir un petit
peu se réveiller et met les bouchées
doubles lames enfin la réponse allait
elle est assez simple sur le fait qu'ils
aient commencé l'entraînement un peu
trop tard ou qui pas du tout encore pas
encore commencé ils sont pas pros donc
certains pas voir des obligations de
prendre leurs congés au mois d'août
quinze jours trois semaines donc du coup
ben tu pars en vacances parce que la
famille c'est aussi important et donc
ben voilà ils sont obligés de reprendre
l'entraînement un petit peu plus tard
globalement ça va faire un décalage sur
la saison mais les matchs durent
justement sur la préparation physique
est ce qu'ils ne sont pas griller du
coup pour leurs bateaux mais non c'est
oui ils ont un petit peu de retard mais
dans un mois un mois dans un mois le
retard sera sera comblé il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de péril
mais oui en effet lassé c'est dommage de
commencer une saison et de se dire on
part avec un boulet quoi parce qu'on
demande pas trop finalement aux amateurs
de venir plus tôt pour préparer leur
saison
c'est le groupe n'est pas professionnel
après c'est le joueur en a parlé c'est
les moyens que se permettre de donner
les écuries donc ils tombent sur sur un
très bon très bon du de leur groupe
dès le premier match qui a peut-être un
peu plus de un peu plus de moyens et qui
donc peut être indemnisées aussi ses
joueurs
différemment je ne sais pas j'ai pas
tout les
toutes les tout libye du fonctionnement
de la fédérale 2 mai et puis après il ya
en effet la motivation que les
dirigeants je parlais d'entraîneur mais
les dirigeants vont pouvoir donner à
leurs joueurs en se disant cette année
l'objectif les gars faut pas qu'on se
rate et ben peut-être que le message est
mal le message est mal passé
et donc voilà le en voilà le résultat
quoi alexandra parce que vous êtes
d'accord avec yann alors moi la
quatrième division je connais pas du
tout mais j'imagine que la saison est
longue
ils ont quoi une trentaine de matchs ça
dépend s'ils veulent se qualifier un peu
plus haut s'il arrive à se qualifier
donc d'accord voilà c'est loin donc un
match une défaite n'est pas si
inquiétant ça après toujours est il que
je pense que même si ce en 4e division
et qui sont des amateurs il ya plein
d'autres personnes qui aimeraient être à
leur place mon cas à eux de se
débrouiller pour travailler un petit peu
plus et être prêt genre je vous sent
bouillonner depuis le début je vous ai
pas encore donné la parole c'est à vous
non mais ça vous surprend on passe est
oui ça me surprend ça me surprend parce
que
déjà
perdre à la maison le premier match de
championnat c'est jamais bon alors
l'analyse avait aussi perdu à la maison
nos premiers matches s'étaient bobigny
bobigny qui descendait de scélérats lune
là le morceau n'est pas la même à grains
marcq en baroeul c'est une équipe qu'ils
avaient dans la poule l'an dernier et
qu'ils avaient battue assez largement
chez ea plaisir l'an dernier donc c'est
ce qu'elle va partir et voir si les
grosses écuries de leur poule de
commencer la saison avec une lourde
défaite à domicile face à une équipe qui
va jouer le milieu de tableau à mon avis
je sais pas marc andreu qui va les jouer
les autres tableaux c'est quand même
assez inquiétant parce que c'est
peut-être renforcer ce sens ils sont
peut-être encore c'est effectivement et
je le sais rien on verra après
maintenant moi je vous parle de de ce
que j'ai vu l'an dernier marquant murray
n'était pas une grosse équipe
alors je vais se sont peut-être
effectivement renforcée je l'espère pour
plaisir parce qu'après est entraîneur
trouvé comme excuse que la veulent que
les joueurs sont arrivés en retard sur
la préparation physique
c'est très inquiétant parce que là les
marches sanchez 6-1 échelle anoxie sont
pas précis c'était pas prédit vaches
ils seront pas prêts dimanche prochain
dimanche prochain ils vont à
gennevilliers ça va être très difficile
pour eux et donc là va s'instaurer une
spirale ce qui me fait peur c'est
qu'elle s'est instauré lundi rage de
défaites ou là mais rattrapé courir
après 1
un retard physique mais c'est très
compliqué et vu quand même que je ne
pense pas qu'à leur niveau pour avoir un
temps d'une interview en fin de saison
l'an dernier où il comptait jouer la
qualification cette année en fédérale 2
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient eu la
lucidité de voir leur saison l'an
dernier
il faut quand même rappeler
encore une fois c'est un oeil technique
que j'y mets mais ils finissent ils ne
descendent pas et finissent 10e sur 12
parce que ils ont simplement trouvé deux
équipes qui étaient très faible très
faible et c'est uniquement pour ça
qu'ils sont qu'ils se soient maintenus
et j'espère j'espère pour eux qu'ils en
sont conscientes puisque avec 25 points
c'étaient les points qu'ils avaient en
fin de saison l'an dernier avec 25
points sur 16 poules en france dans
toutes les autres poules y descendait
avec 25 points ça ne suffisait pas pour
être maintenu en fédérale 2 dans
n'importe quelle foule donc c'est tout
simplement ils se soient maintenus parce
qu'ils ont trouvé deux équipes très
faible en la personne de domont et arras
donc j'espère que je me la suis dit la
lucidité de se rendre compte que c'est
pas leur niveau de jeu qu'ils ont
spécialement élevés l'an dernier
certainement sur certaines marques ça
fait toujours du bien et ça on apprend
toujours plus ça a évolué un cran au
dessus mais il ya la lucidité et la cinq
étages le dis parce que c'est le premier
match à la maison face à une équipe qui
est qui et qui est dans leurs cordes
mais qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète le plus
la défense ils ont fait huit essais ce
nom mais là quand on perd de façon 4 des
recettes faciles c'est forcément là
était défaillant et faïza au rugby si
vous preniez quand même quelques belles
séquences en attaque
quelques séquences non mais on peut pas
on peut pas se contenter quelques bonnes
séquences vous prenez 50 points à la
maison
la maison et ses plaisirs vous perdez
vous perdez pas très haut 12 au bo vous
perdez pas un point vous pouvez dire là
on a raté notre là vous prenez 50 points
en face à une équipe encore une fois
alors peut-être que ça va être la grosse
équipe du j'y crois pas je vous le dis
moi j'y crois pas donc pour moi c'est
quand même assez inquiétant et de sable
one here on est en retard physique sur
le travail physique travail physique et
technique je pensais la mairie et qu'il
avait fait
un immense à nîmes en saut dans le dalo
technique du groupe
ce sera le mot de la fin sur cette
thématique
après la superbe synthèse de deux jours
miss et son regard technique après cette
page rugby on va parler cyclisme c'est
notre focus du jour en cyclisme sur
piste
une reine est peut-être né à sète et
thématiques de gros est tout juste 19
ans qui s'entraîne presque toutes les
semaines nous le vendent national de
saint quentin en yvelines a remporté la
médaille de bronze en vitesse
individuelle aux championnats d'europe
en écosse à glasgow et elle a surtout
remporté la médaille d'or en keirin de
façon magistrale
dans la foulée elle est devenue
championne de france 2 guérini est
championne de france de vitesse
la question sur ce thème mathilde de
groulx est elle déjà sur le toit du
monde à 19 ans oui ou non
est-ce que c'est déjà la mer partager
j'en fais un petit tour
pourquoi les gens vous êtes partagés non
je pense que c'est parce que la
meilleure année de son plaisir
partenaires sur un maintien des
obédiences va partager non mais à 19 ans
la meilleure la meilleure c'est
peut-être surtout pas faut lui laisser
le temps de faire de faire ses preuves
et de grandir comme on dit dans le sport
elle a 19 ans mais par contre pour moi
elle ira ira très loin et il ira très
loin et elle fait partie pour moi
d'aider des meilleurs actuelle vraiment
et je pense que la prochaine échéance
plus ça va aller et là elle est vraiment
dans des dans les années où elle va où
elle va exploser qu à mon sens pas
spécialiste mais c'était d'essayer un
nom à l'épaule à cet effet d'une
luxation de l'épaule
pascal a voulu aller peut-être un peu
envie donc c'est d'autant plus
c'est d'autant plus honorable ses
résultats surtout qu'elle est parti
s'entraîner à l'étranger depuis
relativement peu de temps elle tire déjà
des bénéfices c'est bien elle est
surnommée participe au championnat du
monde appelle d'or justement cette année
yann et des patins pour ça qu'on ya des
pertes au japon où il pendant pendant
trois mois pour s'entraîner il ya du jeu
riez vous la connaissez bien que les
bien oui on sait le coût de repérage
avant les élections comme on a pu le
voir au golf national
mathilde de gros matile de mathilde wii
fait un très très beau championnat du
monde en remportant le keirin elle pèche
encore sur la vitesse individuelle parce
que le côté tactique et c'est encore
très très compliqué à à ce niveau là
elle manque également cruellement
d'expérience elle a pu combler une
grosse part de son manque d'expérience
en allant au japon pour pour découvrir
le quai riquet et travailler avec le
karine traditionnelle elle voilà le la
scala ce qu'elle a fait ce qu'il faut je
peux aller l'europe c'est très très bien
maintenant on va faire le confirmer au
niveau ce serait bien non c'est
excellent non c'est très bien c'est très
bien ben oui bien sûr parce que
aujourd'hui
mathilde est là qu'une chose en tête
enfin là deux choses en tête la première
chose c'est d'être championne du monde
et la deuxième c'est d'être champion
olympique donc donc temps que ces
échéances là ne seront pas ne seront pas
passées on pourra pas dire si l es la
meilleure on pas aujourd'hui il ya un
élément qui est enfin dommageable pour
pour mathilde c'est la disparition de
christina vogels
oh parmi les sportifs de haut niveau
c'est une athlète c'est donc été imité
les cdo et qui aujourd'hui est
paraplégique et qui est détentrice fac
était là encore man deux titres
olympiques et deux titres de championne
du monde et qu'ils étaient donc sur les
mêmes disciplines que matip et qui
étaient encore jeunes parce qu elle
avait 27 ou 28 ans je crois donc ça
aurait été très très bien pour mathilde
de la rencontrer et de la battre dans
les deux prochaines années
là elle n'aura pas cette chance donc on
pourra toujours se dire est ce que mes
mais voilà le temps fera que mathilde et
risque de prendre une place très très
grande dans le dans l'esprit des des
gens parce qu'elles risquent de marquer
cette discipline part d'une très grosse
empreinte et en plus un par un par un
parcours par un quart parcours très très
très atypique alexandre est ce qu'elle
est déjà prête pour les jo de 2024
à votre avis non mais ça tombe bien vu
que c'est en 2024 donc à la le temps
mais cette performance est superbe
session voilà de 2024 du conseil c'est
encore long qu'est ce qu'elle doit faire
encore votre avis il ya dujarrier pour
progresser travail travail travail et
travail il ya que ça qui l'a
kiki qui récompense le travail qui est
récompensé par par départ des bons
résultats
elle est très intelligente elle est très
bien encadré
sa famille et sa famille a la tête sur
les épaules et wallace et 7 filles aussi
à la tête sur les épaules
ils ont ils ont tout compris elle n'y a
pas de raison que ça ne colle pas les
ajustements ont parlé tout à l'heure de
son voyage au japon est ce que ça l'a
aussi permis peut-être de grandir aussi
ce voyage à laver 19 ans du coup un
certain qu'ils n'ont jamais fait ce
voyage au japon parce que soi disant
c'est trop dur genre est-ce que ça l'a
fait mûrir ce voyage c'est la première
fois que j'entends comme au japon
programme dire même si je ne pense pas
oui toute façon toute expérience est
bénéfique mais je ne suis pas sûr parce
que là je suis pas otage effet de bon
pronostic ilian les a confirmés autant
là je ne sais pas si si si techniquement
tactiquement ou professionnellement son
voyage au japon a été bénéfique
mais ce que je suis certain c'est qu'on
va parler d'elle très très vite puisque
dès la première compétition après le
voyage elle devient championne d'europe
où la première commission internationale
devient championne d'europe de la
discipline qu'elle est allée travailler
là bas
donc voilà les résultats sont des
résultats sont là et ils sont très
rapides
là où vous voyez miser une petite pièce
sur mathilde de gros médaille d'or de
mathilde de gros en 2024 à paris oui
parce qu'elle malgré son jeune âge elle
fait preuve de beaucoup de lucidité
elle est consciente qu'elle a besoin de
passer par des périodes d'aguerrissement
comme le démontre son voyage donc oui je
pense que épuisement mais surtout à la
vie du site
si on veut mais je sais que vous aviez
parlé pendant trois heures sur le
cycliste et sur mathilde qu'on passe
maintenant être dernières pages de la
rubrique débats
dans cette page débat nous allons parler
du nouveau centre d'entraînement du apg
qui sera implanté sur la commune de
poissy les contours du projet ont été
présentés le vendredi 7 septembre à la
mairie
sur les 74 hectares on retrouvera
notamment 17 terrains de football un
stade de 5000 places pour accueillir
notamment les féminines un dojo pour le
judo est un terrain de handball on
écoute le directeur immobilier du psg la
recherche du paris saint germain
aujourd'hui c'est de recréer un lien
avec l'ensemble de ses activités
sportives aujourd'hui nous sommes est
allé sur le territoire parce que ya une
histoire qui s'inscrit de cette manière
là donc on voulait c'est ta première
fois que le toutes les activités
sportives du paris saint germain ont par
s'implanter sur un même lieu
alors le centre sera équipe également
des dernières innovations pour permettre
aux joueurs de récupérer pleinement
après un match ou un entraînement il y
aura notamment un centre de
balnéothérapie dernier cri à l'objectif
de la récupération pour nous et est
primordial quand on voit aujourd'hui
qu'il allait maps et la quantité de
match qui doit jouer tout au long de
l'année
les joueurs jouent de plus en plus
aujourd'hui sont de plus en plus
sollicitée à travers des compétitions à
la fois nationales européennes et
internationales
donc aujourd'hui la récupération est un
élément essentiel de la préparation du
joueur alors le début des travaux est
programmé pour l'été 2010 9 coût total
de l'opération plus de 220 millions
d'euros entièrement financés par le psg
le prix du transfert de neymar voilà que
vous l'avez remarqué il ya du marié la
question sur ce thème ce centre
d'entraînement est il nécessaire pour
devenir un très bon coeur très grand
club je vais y arriver
oui ou non vous êtes une à une sur la
question raul votre avis sur cette
question
j'ai d'abord ça démontre que le
les qataries ont encore une une volonté
de s'inscrire dans le temps avec avec ce
club est de donner une ampleur bien plus
grandes heures au psg
j'imagine que ceux de toute façon le
football récupère une un atout de prêts
supplémentaires avec la victoire des
bleus cet été la nouvelle création d'une
nouvelle ligue on va voir les les
joueurs nationaux jouer de plus en plus
donc mobilisation voilà la ligue des
nations les des joueurs qui vont être
encore plus sollicités physiquement et
médiatiquement donc je pense que c'est
nécessaire c'est nécessaire parce que ça
disons que le système se met à la page
de ce que devient le foot international
actuel hélène vous souhaite aussi
convaincu par ce nouveau centre
d'entraînement du psg après moi j'ai un
peu de mal avec les 220 millions là je
sais pas d'où ça sort je vais vraiment
un club on peut
investir autant alors oui les qatari est
très bien mais voilà
mais n'ont de toute façon il est évident
que meilleure sans lés structures les
différents pôles dans un centre
d'entraînement meilleures seront les
résultats
en tout cas toutes les chances sont là
donc évidemment que c'est c'est quand
même indispensable et c'est ce qui va
faire qu'on n'a plus de chance d'avoir
les meilleurs résultats après m'avoir
genre ya un centre de balnéothérapie est
ce que ça peut faire la différence dans
un match de ligue des champions
puisqu'ils peuvent faire ce qu'il veut
faire la différence
la récupération à leur niveau ils la
font ils la font qu'un avec la france il
a choisi le seul la seule différence
c'est que tout sera regroupé en un droit
il l'a dit lui-même le directeur du
mobilier
il a dit lui même c'est que tous soient
regroupés au même endroit était que
toutes les disciplines aussi soit au
même endroit qui est une entité une
entité globale et ça c'est bien
sincèrement le plus pour moi parce
qu'après tout ce qu'ils font ils le font
déjà
alors au niveau professionnel est
footballeur on prévient que la
récupération
c'est quelqu'un qui joue pas il récupère
ils font que ça mais là il soit tout
sera centralisé et toutes les
disciplines regroupées sur un même site
là ça fait vraiment ont marqué vraiment
parce que il l'a dit lui même
les sections du psg sont un petit peu
par pillé un peu partout on ne sait pas
trop alors que là ce sera tous ont un
site sacré peut être une culture psg oui
je pense je pense que c'est pour marquer
un peu plus lent pred parce qu'en plus /
dif il n'y a pas que le football
ils sont présents quand même handball
une grosse équipe en basket donc et ça
marquera quand même ça ça va ça va
malheureusement le basket pas encore
levé sans nom et y sommes pas intéressés
le handball le judo le judo et le
fougueux le football pas là mais mais ne
l'emballent handball lamballe et à haut
niveau donc donc ça va ça va apporter
une puce soir on va lire revalorisé pour
moi l'enseigne psg paris saint germain
si on se sera vraiment une entité
commune sur un site commun et pour moi
c'était bien avant le club après voilà
voilà c'est une avancée c'est une marche
supplémentaire pour la conquête du titre
européen sous lbo est sûr c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ça va aussi aider à
recruter des grands joueurs il y avait
beaucoup de joueurs comme un peu de mal
à venir à paris
chivu n'est pas parce que les gens
parlent de quelques années les
structures à saint germain était quand
même assez camp des loges étaient pas
été pas top
donc du coup il ya eu quelques quelques
noms venus / / / décor au contrat il ya
quelques années et donc du coup ça peut
aider à faire venir des joueurs dans les
années dans les années à venir
j'ai une petite anecdote sur la
récupération dont tu parles c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui les footballeurs ils ont
pas besoin de rien et marc a été testé
un système de cryothérapie à suresnes
il a adoré le principe est donc du coup
le l'endroit où il a fait la queue au
tapis de la promenade et vous revenez
quand il le dit non non je vais en
acheter une
voilà carrément une machine qui vous
quelques quelques centaines de milliers
d'euros en avoir une chez lui
aujourd'hui genre est d'ordre à ces
quelques questions de crédibilité aussi
également avec son à beaune et il le
disait yann ya quelques instants ça
permet de mettre le club parisien tout
simplement dans le gratin du foot
européen
oui tout à fait j'imagine que ben le
barça le real et tous ces clubs là on a
même chose j'aime bien l'idée que ça
regroupe plusieurs sports ça c'est sympa
mais par contre je rejoins hélène sur le
budget et je vais ajouter ma petite
patte golfique cas là dessus parce que
220 millions nous on a du mal à trouver
des tournois où la somme totale des
gains et trois cent mille euros
hélas dans 220 millions les 620
lorsqu'anne l'argent public ça va quand
même participé à la création de routes
et de ronds points autour du centre bell
et il vaut mieux parce que cela crée un
un stade de 5000 tu as aussi c'est
peut-être ce qui était demandé également
le prêt de 220 millions d'euros c'est
que c'est le prime du football
aujourd'hui le football c'est devenu
quelque chose de
on parle de sommes astronomiques et un
effet qui sont incompréhensibles pour la
plupart des sportifs
aujourd'hui une équipe de cyclisme c'est
le lait les plus gros budget ne dépasse
pas les fins sont autour de 20 millions
donc voilà c'est à dire l'investissement
peut être également un investissement
c'est le qatar veut revendre le club un
jour ils auront le moyen moyen de
surévaluer la bombe qui pourra l'acheter
mais question est là qui pourra
l'acheter aussi c'est un moment quand ça
devient trop cher
vous réduisez les potentiels acquéreurs
cette façon contre d'immobilier à votre
avis raul la culture question d'en
parler tout à l'heure est ce que la
culture psg sera bien présente dans ce
cette structure plus que jamais bien sûr
ces résultats qui font sa culture dwm
mais bon on imagine forcément qu'un tel
investissement il ira dans le sens des
résultats
et puis comme on collectionne le plus en
plus de stars au sein de ce club aura
également un club house où il y aura
tous les maillots des et tout est fait
de toute façon pour qu' il ya une
ambiance
puis je crois que le club
comment dire d'un point de vue public
et puis les plus appréciés qu'avant on
est moins à cheval sur le côté c'est
l'argent des qataris et on est les
premiers à rouler moins voilà on soulève
moins ça et puis je vous dire on a un
peu tous raccrocher que le tabouret
finalement le paris saint-germain
à poissy saint germain oui et du goût
pour l'instant voilà une petite boutique
est ce qu'on change la donne et de
poissy-saint-germain vois ça vous tente
dernière petite info insolite
quand même sur ce centre d'entraînement
genlis il y aura également un potager
dans son antre un jour notamment
récolter des poils qui veulent récolter
des points pas de souci je peux venir je
peux venir le remettre quelques taloches
mais par contre mais par contre si on
fait ça vous puissiez à cautionner les
indices et c'est pas grave mais là ça va
peut-être faire la différence
image du bio sont pas championne
d'europe après ça je comprends plus rien
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouve le 26 octobre prochain pour
cause de ryder cup avant de se quitter
tv 78 a lancé un jeu concours vous
pouvez assister à la rencontre de
handball féminin entre le club de paris
92 et l'équipe de metz le 16 septembre
prochain
pour jouer il vous suffit d'aller sur
notre site internet tv 78 points comme
tout le monde peut jouer même où genre
si vous voulez des places tarif on va
terminer par une citation de tiger woods
peu importe la qualité que vous avez
vous pouvez toujours à l'améliorer et
c'est ce qui est passionnant je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]